foreign
[Music]
Al episode we talk about not one but
many monster movies in series after the
success of Godzilla vs Kong the genres
reached a new Peak which is why we are
happy to introduce you to all the
comparable projects that will be coming
in the next few years among those are
Godzilla vs Kong 2 a Cloverfield sequel
the a quiet place franchise and many
more have fun watching
this year the sequel Meg 2 will hit
theaters the previous film starring
action star Jason Statham won over many
fans and was also a huge financial
success shooting for the new movie with
the gigantic prehistoric shark started
in February 2022 and was concluded in
the same year we will only see a small
number of actors from the first part
again including Jason Statham as Jonas
Taylor and Cliff Curtis who embodies
James maccreitus AKA Mac behind the
scenes an important crew change took
place John Turtle will no longer be in
charge of directing leaving the British
high-rise director Ben Wheatley to take
over instead in terms of story not only
will the great Megalodon give the
characters involved a rough time but the
no less terrifying Kronosaurus will also
make an appearance the lack of an R
rating was one of the first Parts points
of criticism but this could actually
change in the sequel if it goes
according to book author Steve Alta so
you might be in for a darker and even
more brutal experience we are excited
about Meg 2 the trench and look forward
to the theatrical release on August 4th
so far the cooperation between Warner
Brothers and legendary has resulted in
three films with Godzilla most recently
in a Blockbuster in which he initially
battled against and later with King Kong
for movie Fanatics however it is obvious
that a true Godzilla movie must be made
by the Japanese Production Studio Toho
founded in 1932 the company is
responsible for the very first Godzilla
film from 1954 and properly popularized
the radioactive giant lizard in the
Western World Tomo's last project was
the very successful Shin Godzilla from
2016 which is why many fans are already
eagerly awaiting the next installment
which is scheduled for release in 2023
while it is not known to what extent the
film will tie in with its predecessor
the excitement is evident among many
still we will have to wait until the
Japanese Godzilla day on November 3rd
2023 as the Japanese theatrical release
is not slated before that
a quiet place with a true surprise hit
in 2018 the horror flick from director
and lead actor John Krasinski revolves
around monsters to react to the
slightest noise with most deadly
consequences after the sequel already
hit theaters in the summer of 2021 two
more projects are now in the works the
first will be a spin-off a quiet place
day one a prequel that will probably
deal with the arrival of the aliens on
Earth Krasinski himself is only involved
as a producer with Michael sarnosky
taking over as director sarnoski was
able to make a name for himself a while
back thanks to the success of pig with
Nicholas Cage a quiet place day one has
been announced for March 8 2024 and the
official part 3 is scheduled for release
in 2025 though further details are not
yet known
in 2024 we can expect another sequel to
a popular Monster franchise a fourth
film in the Cloverfield series is to be
released on an as yet unknown date the
official title is not known either but
JJ Abrams will once again be the
producer as he was for the previous
films as it became known in 2021 the
movie story will not connect to the
third movie but to the first one from
2008 what exactly this means is
something the people in charge have not
yet disclosed but it can be assumed that
the found footage style of the first
part will not be maintained since the
end of last year we also know that the
acclaimed under the shadow director Baba
kanvari will be in charge of directing
the main goal of the producers including
the Batman director Matt Reeves is
probably to build on the success of the
first part 10 Cloverfield Lane in the
Cloverfield Paradox were also well
received by some yet failed to match the
original in many respects we are
definitely looking forward to the still
Untitled Cloverfield film so far an
exact release date has not been set but
many consider it realistic that it will
be out next year
at some point in the coming years
Guillermo del Toro is expected to direct
one of his passion projects at the
mountains of Madness the original story
is by H.P Lovecraft one of the most
famous authors of the 20th century in
the genre of horror and fantasy Del Toro
has been trying for many years to create
a worthy adaptation and his first
efforts started back in 2006 after many
failed attempts he is now working with
Netflix to make it happen but it is
still uncertain as to when this will
take place on November 10th 2022 we were
able to see a first draft showing a
tentacle monster in front of a snowy
scenery although this is merely test
material from back then the cult
director still seems to be on fire for
his movie adaptation we will update you
as soon as there is any news on the
project
next year it is time for the sequel to
2021's Godzilla vs Kong a movie that was
a Smash Hit during the pandemic and is
now getting a visually stunning sequel
there's already a bit of information
footage from the shooting on Australia's
Gold Coast for example has surfaced
showing dozens of extras fleeing from a
monster coming out of the water in
addition the former enemies Godzilla and
Kong are to fight together against
greater dangers from now on as could
already be seen from the battle against
Mecca Godzilla it can be assumed that
they will delve much deeper into the
world of the Titans exactly which
adversary there will be remains unclear
but will most likely be bigger and
stronger than Mechagodzilla we are
excited to see what returning director
Adam Wingard has in store for us and
look forward to the release which is set
for March 15 2024.
back in 2011 a movie based on the
popular comic book series Monster Hunter
Survival Guide was being planned over 10
years ago the idea was to cast Dwayne
Johnson in the starring role as the
monster hunter in terms of plot John
Paul Russ's miniseries is about a
comprehensive guide on how to hunt
creatures like werewolves and vampires
it is rumored that the project could be
released in the coming years but there's
no more detailed information it is
unclear whether Dwayne Johnson will
continue to be a part of the planet
after his forced departure from a Black
Adam sequel however he surely has some
spare time for new movie adaptations
earlier this month Warner Brothers
signed composer Michael giaccino to
direct the remake of a cult film the
movie in question is them a black and
white horror movie from 1954 that was
the first of its kind to focus on
enormous insects more specifically it is
about a giant ant nest which spreads
fear and Terror and kills people the
cause of the mutations is said to be
nuclear weapons testing which was a
popular theme in 1950s monster movies
giachino has only directed three movies
to date however he can proudly present
an even larger list of film series and
video game music but will that be
helpful for the atmosphere of the
classic remake it's also in question
whether the movie will actually be an
exact remake of the admittedly outdated
original or if they may take more
Liberties the script about the giant
ants is currently still being written we
will make sure to keep you up to date in
our weekly news
a monster series is also currently in
post-production but it is still unclear
when it will be released we're talking
about Skull Island a series about
Castaways who try to escape from the
Mysterious Island and home of King Kong
in doing so not only does the giant ape
get in their way but so do other
prehistoric Titans a first image was
already published the beginning of June
2022 it shows a gigantic footprint of
King Kong and two comparatively tiny
humans in the middle of it Powerhouse
Animation Studios which has already
produced series like Castlevania or
blood of Zeus is behind the production
we are curious to see if and how Skull
Island can ultimately add to the
live-action films and look forward to
the still undisclosed release date
some time ago Apple TV plus acquired the
rights to a series called Godzilla and
the Titans the project by Star Trek
Enterprise writer Chris black and comic
book author Matt fraction is set in the
time after Godzilla and the Titans have
raised San Francisco to the ground and
made everyone aware that monsters are
obviously real the storyline revolves
around a family that sets out to find
the origin of it all and also comes
across the secret organization known as
Monarch there are already some actors
known to be involved including Fast and
Furious 9 actress Anna sawai Justice
League actress Kirsty Clements as well
as the thing actor Kurt Russell and his
son Wyatt Russell who plays in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier there is
no set release date yet but filming for
the series is said to have been
completed so it should only be a matter
of time before we get to see the
monsters in action
this was our original but the most
interesting monster movies and series of
the coming years which monster projects
are you looking forward to the most and
are there any you are missing from our
list feel free to leave us a comment and
don't forget to share the video with
your friends thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]